Florida's coral reef is the only
tropical reef system in the continental
United States it's also the third
largest in the world but the beauty is
vanishing in just one decade the reef
lost nearly half its coral cover the
system stretches more than 300 miles
along Florida's coast
Manuel mejor Hayes is on the boat off
Key Biscayne did show us how citizens
scientists are helping efforts to save
the reef Manuel good morning good
morning what lies beneath us is an
important and delicate part of Florida's
ecosystem massive structures made out of
coral like this but parts of the reef
look like a forest with no trees so
scientists along with the help of some
certified divers are trying to replant
and regrow the reef the beauty of South
Florida's coastline isn't just skin deep
below the water lies a crucial habitat
of coral home to hundreds of species of
marine plants and animals
Stephanie shop Meyer a University of
Miami marine biologist is working to
save them
and to climate change we set out with
shot Meyer to see the rescue of reef
program in action scientists who are
certified divers are replanting parts of
the reef with the help of citizen
scientists the first task is to collect
recently grown coral from these
so-called trees the group has installed
just off Key Biscayne once they bring
them up the divers are taught how to
secure the harvested coral onto the
ocean floor pull that zip ties then it's
time to find a spot to replant them and
doing that is like underwater gardening
putting down stakes and securing the new
coral all while trying not to drift into
other replanted coral that's already
growing here we're doing a stress test
but it's on dry land where coral
biologists like Roz cunning work to
ensure these corals survive challenging
conditions we are studying the stress
resistance of corals we're trying to
identify which corals are able to
withstand warming temperatures aside
from saving the ecosystem conning says
billions of dollars are at stake from
fishing to tourism
if the reef does not survive it also
helps protect against beach erosion and
another major threat to Florida
hurricanes coral reefs act as a natural
barrier and when hurricanes approach
they act as a first line of defense
against storm surge rescue a reef is
slowly trying to rebuild that line of
defense how many you get planted six
this is Jessica Glen's ninth dive I live
here I'm a poor idea so I want to save
it and Natalie myrtles first I've been
wanting to do this for over a year and
finally today there's no life
rescue Arif is not the only program
working to replant the coral reef
Stephanie shop Meyer told us there is a
network of scientists and divers that
have already replanted tens of thousands
of corals a year but they have a long
way to go
Gail all right Manuel Bojorquez we thank
you oh it's good to see you man